[Musique]
bonjour je suis ravi de vous retrouver
ici depuis bruxelles depuis le coeur du
parlement européen
dans ce nouveau numéro d' europe hebdo
nous allons ouvrir ensemble les portes
de l'europe
et voici le programme comment assurer un
système de retraite pérenne et justes
dans quel pays européen fait-il bon être
retraité des questions au centre du
débat public dont de nombreux pays
l'union et pas qu'en france nous
prendrons la direction la suède qui a
fait le choix d'un système de retraite
universel à points qui garantit une
pension minimum nous questionnerons
entre autres ce modèle avec nos invités
en plateau mais avant tout ce qu'il ne
fallait pas louper dans l'actualité
européenne cette semaine du salaire
minimum européen relancé à l'entrée des
élus indépendantistes catalans ici au
parlement européen s'est résumé pour
vous comme chaque semaine par aurélia
fasse le break site aura bien lieu le 31
janvier
après trois reports la date du divorce
entre le royaume uni et l'union
européenne
et cette fois-ci fixée le 9 janvier
dernier la chambre des communes a
définitivement adopté l'accord conclu
avec bruxelles
trois ans et demi après le référendum en
faveur de la sortie de l'union
européenne mais les négociations ne sont
pas pour autant terminés va désormais
s'ouvrir une période de transition
onze mois pour négocier les contours de
la future relations entre le royaume uni
et l'union
en attendant les britanniques
continueront d'appliquer les règles
européennes
jusqu'au 31 décembre 2020
la croatie prend la présidence tournante
de l'union européenne le pays assure
depuis le 1er janvier sa première
présidence le plus jeune membre de
l'union succède à la finlande et affiche
des objectifs différents de son
prédécesseur zagreb milite pour un
maintien du budget de la politique de
cohésion pour une union plus forte
un revirement après la présidence
finlandaise marqué par une politique
d'austérité
[Musique]
le salaire minimum européen est relancé
la commission européenne a commencé à
consulter les partenaires sociaux sur ce
sujet c'était une promesse d'ursula von
der leyen lors de son élection à la tête
de la commission
l'idée n'est pas de proposer un salaire
minimum universel pour tous les citoyens
de l'union ni d'obliger les pays à fixer
un salaire minimum mais de faire
converger progressivement les smic
nationaux aujourd'hui 22 pays de l'union
européenne ont établi un salaire minimum
entrée des élus indépendantistes
catalans au parlement européen trois
leaders catalans avait été élu député en
mai dernier mais aucun d'entre eux
n'avait encore pu siéger au sein de
l'institution européenne poursuivie en
espagne pour tentative de sécession
en décembre la justice européenne leur a
ouvert les portes du parlement
en reconnaissant leur immunité
parlementaire carlès peluche damon et
tony comines ont donc siéger en tant
qu'eurodéputé pour la première fois la
semaine dernière mais sans oriol
junqueras emprisonnés en espagne
condamnés à l'automne à 13 ans de prison
et d'inéligibilité
[Musique]
victor fernandez sordo bonjour bienvenue
vous êtes historien chercheur au centre
pour l'histoire contemporaine et digital
à l'université du luxembourg et
spécialiste de la question catalan
on vient de le voir en images 2d 3-0
députés catalans ont finalement fait
leur entrée au parlement européen vous
nous dites quoi enfin il était temps
ça m'apparaît normal dans la mesure où
les acteurs judiciaires européens ici la
cour européenne de justice ainsi que le
parlement européen ont trouvé cela
normal
don du court c'est légitime qu'il soit
est élu au parlement européen
peut-on parler d'une petite victoire
pour la cause catalan pour les
indépendantistes catalans tout à fait on
peut parler d'une petite victoire
notamment dans la pratique ce qui se
passe pour monsieur bouge tellement
c'est que pour la première fois depuis
qu'il a été déchu de ses fonctions de
président de la catalogne il ya deux ans
il peut et avoir une tribune politique
voilà pour s'exprimer mais c'est
notamment victoire dans la mesure où
cela permet de du rhdp anisé la question
catalan se quittant l'objectif à terme
des indépendantistes catalans depuis un
certain temps déjà on va y revenir mais
pour que nos téléspectateurs comprennent
bien pourquoi calais ce putsch manqué et
tony communes ne sont ils pas venu
siéger plus tôt au parlement européen
mais est ce que la commission électorale
espagnole et
mais prétexté que est commise et ils
sont élus en espagne mais qu' ils sont
pas électeur en espagne ils pouvaient
pas siéger dont du coup la commission
électorale et espagnol aura refusé de
leur fournir l'accréditation qui leur
permettraient de siéger au parlement
européen
pour résumer la cour de justice
européenne vous disiez a rendu un arrêt
dans lequel elle estime que les trois
eurodéputés catalans ont acquis leur
immunité parlementaire dès leur élection
en mai 2019
est-ce que cela constitue un revers pour
l'espagne mais également pour les
institutions européennes pour la
commission pour le parlement je pense
que pour les institutions européennes
simplement celle à contribuer à établir
un précédent juridique et un précédent
même politique concernant le droit à la
représentation politique et dévoilait de
11 en cas de figure très particulier qui
est celui de c3 est lui aussi mais je
pense que ce n'est pas forcément un
tournant c'est tout ça permet tout
simplement de deux de réaffirmer le
droit européen concernant cette question
aussi après pour l'espagne la situation
un peu plus complexe effectivement la
situation non seulement politiques mais
aussi judiciaire aujourd'hui en espagne
concernant la question catalan rêvait
d'une énorme complexité et on l'est
toujours aujourd'hui en train de voir
comment les choses évoluent et puis vous
l'avez déjà un petit peu abordé il ya la
situation de ce troisième le député
catalan oriol l'union queyras il est
emprisonné en espagne et à l'occasion de
sa première entrée au parlement européen
le leader indépendantiste carlos pimenta
a eu une pensée pour son compagnon
écouter mister john kanas made by among
acheter des danses qu'ils commettent
hadas mort d'anne myriam vote monsieur
junqueras doit être parmi nous
aujourd'hui car il a recueilli comme
nous plus d'un million de voix mais
malheureusement il y à un état membre de
l'union européenne l'espagne qui ne
respectent pas l'état de droit en europe
et nous sommes ici pour rappeler que la
crise catalan n'est pas une affaire
interne mais une affaire européenne
reese catalan n'est pas une affaire
c'est ce que dit à calais 7 juin est ce
que vous êtes d'accord avec cela
là je suis d'accord avec lui
effectivement ce n'est plus une affaire
et espagnols de le moment où la justice
européenne et les institutions
européennes doivent aussi se prononcer
et de le moment où notamment ces trois
personnes qui ont été élus membres du
parlement européen européen et se trouve
face à une situation qui doit être
dénouée par la justice européenne union
européenne sur ces dossiers sensibles et
en particulier sur la crise catalan qui
divise en espagne a toujours été plutôt
sur une ligne non interventionniste est
ce que c'est une bonne chose est ce
qu'elle va être obligé peut-être de
bouger là dessus donc l'union européenne
effectivement bon l'union européenne en
fait dans la pratique ce sont plusieurs
institutions qui ont leurs propres
compétences à elle mais effectivement
bas les institutions de la prise de
décision notamment le conseil la
commission sans rester très prudent dans
ce n'est pas de notre compétence ça ne
nous regarde pas maintenant le parlement
européen va être amené à se prononcer
sur la continuité de l'immunité
parlementaire des messieurs pour simone
et comines donc dans quelques semaines
dans quelques mois on verra le parlement
européen a voté pour ou contre la
permanence de ces deux personnes c'est
une question épineuse pour l'europe et
cela pourrait créer un précédent pour
les autres indépendantistes européen
il ya des velléités 1 pour la flandre
pour le pays basque ou encore les causes
j'imagine que il regarde tout cela avec
attention tout à fait une question
hautement afin qu'ils rêvaient d'une
haute complexité qui aura des
conséquences si pour d'autres régions
qui ont des velléités indépendantistes
et notamment pour le pays basque en
espagne qui est aussi une autre gens qui
qui a des velléités indépendantistes
depuis un certain moment déjà nous
aurons sans doute l'occasion d'en
reparler merci victor fernandez soriano
d'être venu répondre à nos questions et
puis maintenant nous allons prendre la
direction de la suède pour un tout autre
sujet en 1998 ce pays a choisi le
système de retraite à points
les objectifs affichés à l'époque
simplifier le système et réaliser des
économies
vingt ans après quelle est la situation
des retraités suédois fabien becker est
allé à leur rencontre
[Musique]
un char d'un ouvrier en banlieue de
stockholm même l'hiver
inger stark aime passer du temps dans sa
petite parcelle
mais pour cette retraitée jardiner ce
n'est pas uniquement un hobby je cultive
parce que c'est une activité que j'aime
bien mais aussi parce que ça me fait
faire des économies je fais pousser des
poivrons des tomates dans la serre mais
aussi des pommes de terre des carottes
et des betteraves avec environ 1200
euros de retraite par mois
inger vie juste au dessus du seuil de
pauvreté suédois
cette mère de quatre enfants a longtemps
travaillé à temps partiel à cause d'un
problème de santé vivent seules elle
fait aujourd'hui partie des perdants du
système de retraite instauré dans les
années 90 je n'ai pas les moyens de
m'acheter de nouveaux vêtements à noël
un coup de pouce de ma fille m'a permis
de m'en offrir quelques uns mais je n'ai
pas les moyens de faire des cadeaux à
mes petits enfants
je pense que notre système de retraite
n'est pas bon avant c'était plus
avantageux le calcul de notre retraite
se basait sur nos quinze meilleures
années de salaire
ce n'est plus le cas
la suède s'est dotée en 1998 d'un régime
de retraite universel le même pour tous
les suédois fonctionnaires ou employés
du privé
il prend en compte l'ensemble de la
carrière
le système fonctionne comme un plan
d'epargne tout l'argent que vous cotisez
est accumulée sur un compte
et quand vous choisissez de partir à la
retraite on calcule votre pension en
divisant la somme qu'il ya sur le compte
par le nombre d'années qu'ils vous
restent à vivre selon l'espérance de vie
moyenne géré par l' agence nationale des
retraites
le système garantit à chacun une pension
minimum mais il est d'abord conçu pour
ne jamais être en déficit
la stabilité financière du système est
automatique
il n'y a pas de finances magique toutes
les variations se répercute
automatiquement sur le montant des
pensions en 2010 et en 2011
après la crise financière le niveau des
pensions a b c est qu en suisse
les suédois saft en tout cas qu'ils ne
peuvent pas compter seulement sur le
régime universel de retraite pour
assurer leurs vieux jours
je travaille beaucoup en tant que
freelance et je ne suis pas sûr de
cotiser suffisamment si je fais ça trop
longtemps je n'aurai pas beaucoup
d'argent pour ma retraite et ça
m'inquiète un peu
je fais des économies depuis plusieurs
années déjà et j'espère que je vais
travailler le plus longtemps possible
mais chacun de prendre ses
responsabilités pour plus tard en plus
du régime général
les suédois bénéficient d'une retraite
complémentaire financée par leur
entreprise
l'épargné privée vient ensuite compléter
le dispositif
chaque citoyen est encouragé à y
recourir
et il n'est jamais trop tôt pour
commencer
[Musique]
à 32 ans annette enseigne le suédois et
les mathématiques dans cette école de
stockholm cette année pour la première
fois elle a commencé à épargner pour sa
retraite
je mets un peu de mon argent de côté
chaque mois pour le futur je me
renseigne auprès de personnes de mon
entourage qui m'aident à le placer
correctement
j place beaucoup d'espoirs le système de
retraites fait l'objet d'un large
consensus au parlement
il est le fruit d'un compromis entre
plusieurs partis dont les sociaux
démocrates les conservateurs et même les
verts cette députée du parti de gauche
appartient aux rares voix qui en appelle
à une réforme du système
certes notre système est autofinancé
mais cela se fait sur le dos des
retraités modestes
ce sont eux qui jouent le rôle de
stabilisateur voir d'airbag
quand les temps sont durs nous proposons
de revenir à un système de retraite qui
soit plus redistributif
enfin en suède il faut attendre d'avoir
67 ans pour obtenir une retraite à taux
plein une incitation à travailler plus
longtemps
qui n'a pas encore porté ses fruits en
moyenne les suédois prennent leur
retraite à 64 ans quitte à toucher une
pension moins élevé
[Musique]
et j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir sylvie
brunet élu récemment ici au parlement
européen vous êtes française modem et
vous êtes donc rattachée ici au groupe
re news avons côté en face evelyne
gebhardt eurodéputés allemands depuis
1994 au sein du groupe des socialistes
et démocrates bienvenus et enfin benoît
lutgen vous êtes belge député européen
ici sous l'étiquette du groupe
conservateur le ppe sylvie brunet le
modèle suédois et des souvent cité en
exemple en france emmanuel macron s'en
serait inspiré dans le reportage on en
voit pourtant les limites le système
financier est certes à l' équilibre mais
il ya des perdants
est ce que c'est un modèle selon vous à
suivre assez à des modèles qui peut être
intéressant mais je pense qu'il faut
toujours se raccrocher aux systèmes
tournant dans notre pays à la culture
notre pays au système social qu'on a
dans d'autres pays qui n'est pas du tout
de même que la suède
donc on peut s'en inspirer s'est inspiré
pour certaines causes puisque comme
partout en europe
en france la population vieillit plus
longtemps donc on a plus de retraités -
de naissance globalement on a un petit
peu plus en france et on a ce problème
démographique
donc comment finances de retraite par
répartition donc c'est le vrai sujet est
la vraie question
en suède la valeur du point elle n'est
pas fixant les pensions elles peuvent
baisser dans les périodes de crise et
c'est déjà arrivé
est ce que vous trouvez ce système
justement halinghen non il n'est pas
juste mais on est tous confrontés tous
les gouvernements européens pratiquement
sont confrontés au même problème ça
vient d'être évoqué une faible natalité
dans la plupart des pays européens une
croissance économique qui est faible et
donc de moins en moins de personnes
quelque part qui payent le retrait parce
qu'il faut bien comprendre dans notre
système actuel ce sont les actifs les
travailleurs qui payent la pension de
chaque retraité chaque nom et est donc
on doit tous effectivement se poser la
question suivante soit on doit augmenter
les taxes et nous sommes contre pour
pouvoir financer les retraites
je trouve d'ailleurs qu'on n'a pas
reparlé de réforme de retraite c'est le
sauvetage des retraites parce qu'il faut
pouvoir sauver quelque part c'est
retraite
deuxième élément on réalise des
économies s'allieront baisse
effectivement le niveau de pension
inacceptable ou la troisième possibilité
c'est effectivement d'allonger
un tout petit peu la durée du travail
mais en restant dans un système qui doit
être solidaire de solidarité entre
l'ensemble des générations pour pouvoir
effectivement le financer on le voit
également dans le reportage les ses
doigts ils ont intégré qu'ils ne
poussent ils devraient avoir recours à l
épargne privée c'est nécessaire et
venues des barques pour garantir dans la
durée des retraites avec un financement
équilibré
disons que c'est une chose que l'on fait
en allemagne aussi mais nous voyons très
bien où sont les limites
alors qu'est-ce de ce système et je
pense que nous devons faire en sorte de
revoir vraiment généralement les
systèmes de retraite dans les états
membres
en allemagne par exemple nous avons déjà
aujourd'hui un terme qui s'appelle alto
samut que l'on ne peut pas vraiment
traduire en français est la pauvreté des
personnes âgées et surtout des femmes
c'est l'ancien maire très bientôt voilà
exactement les remy est beaucoup
beaucoup de retraités pauvres la moyenne
de retraite pour les femmes est en ce
moment à 991 euros alors vous parlez
avec ça vous ne pouvez pas vivre et je
pense que là il faut faire quelque chose
en belgique également il ya eu des
tentatives de réforme il ya deux ans
notamment je crois que des questions la
retraite à points est donc une réforme
pour augmenter l'âge légal de la pension
quelque part d'augmenter la durée de
carrière pour pouvoir financer le
système
et il ya toute la question du système à
points comme on l'a vu en suède mais en
fait ensuite c'est quoi ça ne l'est pas
une force est ni plus ni moins il ya peu
de solidarité finalement dans le système
alors vous vous êtes pour cela
non moi je suis pour effectivement qu'on
puisse d'abord relever et soutenir les
pensions les plus faibles
il n'est pas normal dans notre société
aujourd'hui que des retraités ne puisse
pas faire face à leurs besoins primaires
quand vous savez dans mon pays en
belgique que la moyenne quelque part
pour quelqu'un qui a une carrière
complète ses 1200 86 euros de pension
quelqu'un qui a fait une carrière
complète
c'est très peu et que l'accès à une
maison de retraite et de 15 cents euros
en moyenne par mois en voie d accès
impossible pour une personne beaucoup de
personnes de pouvoir tout simplement
aller en maison de retraite ne fût ce
que pour cela
et donc oui le système il doit pouvoir
continuer à être solidaire
ça veut dire ceux qui ont les épaules un
peu plus large davantage contribué pour
avoir et faire exercer la solidarité à
l'égard de chacune et chacun
je suis pour un sauvetage on peut pas
rester dans la situation de
l'immobilisme
je ne comprends pas ce qui se passe en
france enfin je le comprends mais je le
dire cette colère et cette violence
exprimée alors qu'il faut effectivement
pouvoir réformer suis pas d'accord
nécessairement avec le tout le système
qui est mis en place en france est autre
chose mais en tout cas il faut au moins
se poser cette question et prendre des
mesures sinon on ne pourra plus payer
oui en france comme en belgique comme
ailleurs les pensions c'est ça dont il
existe un france les français ont peur
et quand on regarde dans vos dans vos
pays respectifs en allemagne et en
belgique des retraités pauvres les
français ils font peut-être figure de
privilégiés sylvie brunet mais il ya
quand même cette peur de devenir un
retraité pauvres et de ne plus pouvoir
vivre correctement
alors ce qui est curieux vous avez
raison c'est 70% je crois des français
est favorable à cette réforme au départ
notamment parce qu'à 42 régimes spéciaux
et si on veut sauver ce régime par
répartition ce qui est quand même un des
grands objectifs de cette réforme de
sauver ce système par répartition auquel
je retiens beaucoup en france
il faut bien qu'on aille vers quelque
chose de plus adapté de plus universel
et des régimes spéciaux qui ont été mis
en place en 1945 bien tout ce que les
métiers ont évolué et qu'il faut prendre
en compte le sujet de la pénibilité et
ce n'est pas de dire que tout le monde
doit partir plus tard à la retraite le
prendre en compte
en tenant compte des évolutions donc les
français ou comme beaucoup dans les
européens ont cette crainte
effectivement de la précarité une
diminution de la retraite et à des
objectifs aussi de cette réforme c'est
justement de mettre un minimum de 1000
euros par mois la retraite pour tout le
monde notamment les agriculteurs dont
des toutes petites retraites alors
qu'ils ont cotisé toute leur vie on note
grandes inégalités dans notre système et
viennent gebhart la pénibilité au
travail
elle est prise en compte dans le système
des retraites allemand les prises en
compte mais pas assez comme pas assez
puisque nous avons élevé d
le départ en retraite à 66 ans
maintenant je sois jusqu'à 67 ans 2024
la banque centrale de francfort propose
69 ans alors c'est franchement mais pour
tous et je pense que ça on ne peut pas
le faire la pénibilité doit être prise
en compte par ce que il ya certains
métiers que ce soit du point physique ou
psychique qui sont très très difficile
et on ne peut pas dire à une infirmière
par exemple qui est un travail très
lourds très durs qu'elle ne pourra
partir qu'à l'âge de 69 ans pour avoir
sa retraite complète qui sera une
retraite d'ailleurs déjà très minime
très faibles donc il faut faire
attention à ce genre de choses et je
pense qu'une des erreurs que nous avons
fait en allemagne ça a été justement de
dire qu'il nous faut trois piliers une
fois la retraite légale la retraite
professionnelle mais ça dépend des
d'aider les entreprises qui a tout le
propose
et justement les assurances des fonds
d'aidé des fonds privés qui n'apporte
rien en ce moment donc qui donne de gros
gros problème et je pense que cela il
faut faire une révision complète
il y à de grandes disparités en europe
notamment sur l'âge de départ légal à la
retraite
il s'étale de 60 ans pour les femmes en
hongrie et en pologne à 67 ans pour les
allemands le 10e plus de peut-être 69
ans un jour comment on fait peut-être
pour un petit peu converger c'est un
consensus un peu plus générale moi je
pense qu'on doit on doit pouvoir
converger l'europe a un rôle à jouer en
la matière le rate un rôle à jouer en la
matière sur la question des retraites je
pense tout en tenant compte évidemment
de la réalité de chaque pays puisqu'il
ya des réalités différentes sur le plan
démographique notamment même si elles
sont pas immenses il ya bien des
différences qui peuvent exister
le système à points je reviens
simplement là dessus il crée une grande
incertitude
pourquoi la valeur du point elle est
elle peut elle est variable
donc ça peut créer ans elle expliquait
donc ça peut créer une grande angoisse
je pense plus angoissant france elle est
due à cela notamment
deuxième élément sur la pénibilité on
doit regarder ça aussi me semble-t-il
sur les aménagements
de fin de carrière pour faire en sorte
que le travail en fin de carrière soit
adaptée vous avez pris l'exemple d'une
infirmière on peut prendre une
institutrice maternelle à 65 ans 66 ans
avec un 30 30 enfants c'est pas possible
on va pouvoir lui aménager son temps de
travail donc c'est impossible de
regarder via le système des retraites
sans qu'on le prenne en compte l'aspect
de l'aménagement du temps de travail et
donc l'europe oui je pense peut donner
des indications des recommandations en
tout cas en la matière pour faire en
sorte que le système soit le plus
harmonisées possibles pourquoi qu'est ce
qu'on voit sinon il ya aussi et on le
voit très bien
certains retraités qui pour des raisons
fiscales cette fois parfois bouge à
l'intérieur de l'europe parce que les
systèmes sont extrêmement différents et
celui qui a les moyens quelques portes
il peut effectivement en ce moment là
aller chercher le système le plus
favorable ce n'est pas normal donc
l'harmonisation elle permettrait
certainement d'avoir une plus grande
force et une plus grande cohérence sur
le plan européen et l'europe elle fait
des recommandations sur ces questions là
en ce moment s'il venait pas sur la
retraite qui relève de la politique de
chaque état membre
en revanche ce qu'on va commencer à
traiter sur le salaire minimum européen
a forcément un lien donc forcément à
unia et va avoir une application sur sur
la retraite mais je vous rejoins il
yad'autres politique sur l'emploi des
seniors par exemple qui est un vrai
sujet aussi parce que dans beaucoup de
nos pays va jouer le taux d'emploi des
seniors rsa à faire l'âne est renversant
conserver 4 et 65 ans il n'est pas très
élevé en europe 1 de manière générale en
moyenne 40%
donc on a un sujet sur l'emploi des
seniors sur la santé au travail la
prévention que cette pénibilité ou là on
a comme des agences qui travaille sur
ces sujets on a hélas je pense que c'est
des points intéressants mais pas
forcément l'âge de la retraite lui-même
qui relève quand même de la politique de
chaque pays
evelyne gebhardt est ce que vous êtes
pour une tentative d'harmonisation des
systèmes de retraites non non je pense
que cela relève
vraiment de la politique dans les états
membres
parce que les systèmes sociaux sont
tellement différents que si l'on touche
à un point il faut regarder le tout et
je pense que là il faut faire à temps
très attention mais justement ce que
vous avez dit je suis tout à fait
d'accord sur tous ces points de
travailler pour clarifier une chose
aussi
le spd est contre la retraite à 69 ans
je voudrais bien le préciser qu'on ne
compte qu on le sait pour cette union
européenne alors certes c'est de la
confiance
la compétence des états membres la
question des retraites mais elle défend
thème le droit à la retraite comme un
grand principe dans son socle des droits
sociaux en disant qu'il faut pouvoir
avoir une retraite minimum tout aux
femmes décemment
est ce que c'est le cas dans tous les
pays de l'union européenne n'ont pas
clairement non c'est pas le cas dans
dans beaucoup de pays puisqu'on voit que
les de retraites les plus faibles
notamment pour les femmes parce qu'elles
ont à une carrière qui est différente
qui est qui et plus saccadé on va dire
notamment où les temps partiels c'était
très bien exprimé dans votre reportage
qui étaient de grande qualité à cet
égard il ya effectivement des personnes
qui sont en grande précarité et donc oui
l'europe dit quoi on doit avoir la
dignité pour chaque chakra
or c'est pas ce n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui j'ai pas envie moins de
monde que ce soit dans mon pays en
belgique où que ce soit ailleurs en
europe on voit certaines images comme on
le voit dans les pays anglo saxons aux
états unis wire des personnes qui ont 75
ans 80 ans sont obligés d'être aux
caisses des grands magasins pour
empaqueter les
les courses des différents clients non
ça ce n'est pas possible et en même
temps chacun doit pouvoir comprendre que
l'adaptation du temps de travail
permettra de financer l'ensemble du
système et de la solidarité qu'on doit
pouvoir exercer pour tous l'union
européenne elle soutient plutôt à la
réforme menée par la france en tout cas
elle avait encouragé en disant que pour
une question de respect des équilibres
budgétaires il fallait réformer ce
système des retraites il venait oui on a
on a une responsabilité en tant que
politique
on peut pas laisser dériver complètement
et rendre déficitaires des régimes de
retraite
d'autres régimes sociaux donc c'est un
point de vue que moi j'approuve
totalement et donc on se doit en
responsabilité je trouver des solutions
émergent des raisons est sûre même des
milliards voilà non mais c'est pas
possible on peut pas défendre
comment on va défendre que des personnes
pas mieux pour elles partent à 55 ans à
retraite et que le même métier dans un
autre régime professionnels y compris en
france on va partir dix ans plus tard il
ya un moment donné il faut une certaine
égalité pour maintenir ce système
donc je comprends que l'union européenne
soutienne ça justement evelyne gebhardt
vu d'allemagne est ce que les retraités
français ils font figure de privilégiés
ils font figure de privilégiés et les
retraités allemands aimeraient bien
avoir la même situation que les
retraités français et c'est pour ça je
dis très clairement un fait attention en
france à ne pas aller dans le même sens
la même situation qu'en allemagne parce
que c'est une catastrophe pour les
personnes âgées et il faut faire très
très attention à ce qui se fait
cela ne signifie pas qu'il ne faut pas
faire de réformes nous pensons aussi en
allemagne devoir faire des réformes dans
le sens que tous cotisent par exemple
dans une même retraite dans un même
système social en allemagne c'est une
des choses dont nous discutons en ce
moment justement pour pour aider les
fonds de retraite pour pour avoir des
arrivées est aussi nous disons très
clairement dans le spd que nous avons un
régime dans lequel jusqu'à incertain
jusqu'à environ 10000 euros 2
l'argent que l'on ne gagne de revenus on
paye je ne suis plus combien de porc ce
pourcentage pour les retraités
ensuite c'est plafonné et nous disons
pourquoi est-ce que c'est plafonnier
pourquoi est-ce que le mail ionnaires
système juin la mûre et marc de oui
pourquoi est-ce que le millionnaire paye
la même chose que celui qui a dix mille
euros donc on verra si vous arriverez à
un mollet on allait en allemagne merci
ce seront les mots la fin merci à tous
sur notre plateau c'est la fin de cette
émission vous pouvez la voir en replay
sur le site internet de public sénat
mais aussi sur l'antenne de la rtbf à
très bientôt pour de nouvelles aventures
européennes
[Musique]